like I've interviewed guys where their
kids are down the road from them and
they can't see them and the truth of the
matter especially in England it is
really bad the divorce system here a
woman can make one phone call and kick
you out of the house that you pay for
now you're on the hook for the house
that you pay for you still have to pay
for it then she could put you on child
support until you even get a fair day in
trial when coven happened this this went
for like one to two years A lot of them
didn't even get to court so they're
paying child support they haven't seen
their kids and they're kicked out of the
house that they that they're in on top
of that a lot of lawyers and women's
shelters advise them to claim abuse and
they'll use an expanded definition of
abuse and they tell the women to do this
so these men will just be ruined and a
lot of them get so stressed out they
lose their jobs if they can't pay they
get thrown in jail and they can't see
their kids